we both came of age right at the right
at the dawn so we've been there since
day dot it's it's a real honor it's a
real honor and then on the other hand
it's a real sort of fanboy geek out it's
about yeah it feels surreal I didn't
really sink in until we saw the film for
the first time Oh rebellion is all that
remains to push back the Empire I was
not just the fan I mean a huge fan I
would say I grew up watching watching
these films and probably in episode 4 is
one of the first films I really
connected with its and the special
feeling to be part of something that
matters so much that he's been present
for such a long time in my life the
power that we are dealing with hair is
immeasurable it's one of these things
where you have to take your fanboy head
off because it's it's tricky you're
standing in the midst of something you
grew up with and you're flabbergasted
and but you you can't tell anyone so you
have to focus but then luckily get some
breaks and then I can take it all we
have hope
rebellions are built on hope just a joy
it really has been a jury from start to
finish you know you can't have a bad day
on a Star Wars ex there's always some
kind of weird creature walking around
with tentacles coming out of its mouth
and it's just every day there's
something new
[Music]
you
[Music]
you